there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello out there it's episode
134 and guess what
we're talking about another serial
killer BTK yeah Dennis Oh Dennis Rader
yeah
he's old dictator yeah dog catcher and
grass measurer he'd mention your grass
measurer yeah I measure your grass and
then try to rape you yeah you weren't in
a good dude
uh no well here's the thing it's like
all of these dudes are [ __ ] yeah
obviously that should go without saying
this guy I mean Ted Bundy pisses me off
a lot this guy pisses me off yeah a
little bit more I think it's just
because I mean if you watch like the
videotapes of his confession cuz they
videotaped his confession you know it's
about 45 minutes long you can find it on
YouTube yeah of him just like very
calmly like recounting all of the crimes
that he committed to the judge yeah in
third person is if somebody else did it
um well he did but he uses kind of like
yeah it uses like weird like euphemistic
yeah like and you know if they were
killed or yes and then she was killed
yeah yeah you did it dude yeah it was
just really and he just gave herself I
said I didn't I killed her you know well
she was killed and then the one time
like the one time that I really really
just wanted to like punch him right in
the dick yeah was when he was talking
about one of the one of the murders and
then at one point he's just like like he
was just so bored with everything and I
was just like oh Jesus Christ like
somebody really needs to I don't
remember you weren't reading into it
maybe he was tired of talking about it
or something like that or it could have
been but it really sounds like he's
probably trying to sound
like it was terrible yeah that's not how
it came but he didn't give a [ __ ]
he was very artificial and very robotic
and weighted yeah he acted and we're
gonna get into detail you know yeah
right and the thing about him too that
creeps me out I mean yeah it's had Bundy
got away with it for a long time you
know but BTK he got away with it for
30-something here he was married he had
kids he had like a normal life you know
that job doing this to other people's
families yeah he just like did it every
now and then and like nobody ever and
and when they caught him every single
person that knew him like in his family
his friends his co-workers and stuff
weren't [ __ ] shocked to they could
not believe it well he you know put on
the face of a fine upstanding man and an
authority figure and a guy who was for
help in the community yeah but secretly
he was BTK and I find torture and kill
yeah that's what we're talking about he
gave himself that he because he was one
that sent like the letters yeah like
taunting the police and he gave them a
helpful list of suggestions for like
what his name should be and one of them
was BTK and that was the one that stuck
the other ones were stupid [ __ ] like the
Annihilator yeah a lot in I'll eat or
yeah no it was fellow the ER yeah later
and I think it only had one end I don't
know yes I I think he had kind of a
learning disability cuz that dudes
grammar was I've seen some bad grammar
and spelling in my time but holy [ __ ]
like he seemed like he could talk and he
like had normal intelligence but when he
wrote he just sounded like a huge dummy
some you know it was holding him back
his problems were holding him back you
know he couldn't he couldn't be the man
he wanted to be he wanted be a cop yeah
you know yeah he was one of this cop
he's one of those guys I'm gonna be a
cop which each cut each culture in each
country kind of has a different profile
of a guy that wants to be a cop yeah
they're not all bad here in the United
States you know I think probably on a
good professional police force the
average guys okay but you also have to
consider
that the average cop that isn't on the
job very long through four years mostly
nice
he's usually fired or quits yeah you
know but he was one of the particular
type of guys that wants to be a cop
wants to be a soldier wants to do this
and that wants to be Special Forces but
really he can't do it he's not he's not
the kind of guy well he's just average
he's just like an average dude and
that's not good yeah they're not looking
for average guys in any fighting forces
they're looking for [ __ ] dudes there
so it makes them angry that they're not
like better than everybody else
yeah so when they get like a little bit
of power a little bit of authority they
will abuse the [ __ ] out of it yeah you
know I've also heard civilians you know
kind of recently argued about people
have a right to serve their country and
militaries don't see it that way
serving is a privilege and especially in
those tough units it's [ __ ] hard to
get in there you know what I mean you're
gonna see a badasses you're trying to be
the badasses of the baddest of asses you
got to pass all these [ __ ] rights of
passage all these tests all these
quality control stuff and guys like this
don't don't cycle don't why they don't
have it I mean when he was in the Air
Force that's easy
not no offense to God but your average
Harry that's Vivian yeah he was just
like he was like a technical oh yeah
that's antennas that's like a regular
job yeah dudes like a Raider wannabe
cops they want to be Army Rangers they
want to be Special Forces they want to
be Navy SEALs they want to be something
distinguished but man look they can't
have you can't no yeah physically
psychologically the motivation that the
type of motivation the guys that can do
that real well are not looking for
status they're just kind of driven to do
it yeah so they're not trying to impress
other people well see that's what I
always feel I'm like look if you were
really about us you wouldn't have to
tell people yeah you were about it you
would just be one and everyone would
recognize that you would have to say
anything
Raider was the kind of guy to go to bar
and [ __ ] tell everybody he's a Navy
SEAL
yeah I mean he does seem like that good
man I used to hear that a lot and bars
I'm a Navy SEAL yeah
you know you started asking them
questions and yeah it's like it's so
easy to like check that I'm a Navy SEAL
especially now that everybody has
smartphones it's like so some dude comes
up to you in a bar and like tries to hit
on you and be like I'm tired maybe not
that most women would give a [ __ ] and
that would not press them anyway but you
could very easily like look on your
phone no civilian name that's what I
mean that's what I mean yeah most people
that are really cool won't tell people
about their goal she can vouch for this
I kept running into a guy to club and I
had a lot in common with him and I knew
he was military I didn't find out for
sure two years later to the to his SF he
special forces oh and yeah even tell me
I know you're talking about
you wouldn't even tell me yeah yeah he
was very tight-lipped about yeah so
those dudes you know even like when you
asked him out right he was kind of yeah
non-committal then I went over to his
house one time and just saw him pictures
of his graduation photo from the queue
yeah cute course and there he was he was
a e6 so he could totally go around
saying that he was Special Forces yeah
anybody tries but he would he doesn't
even even tell me and he knew I was
prior service you know I was infantry
yeah yeah he wouldn't tell me
she knows the dude she knows who he is
and we have friends of ours who did
photo shoots with him and stuff too cuz
he was a photographer you guys take
pictures yeah you know [ __ ] girls
dressed up in military gear and he you
know his school you know but anyway he
was uh he wouldn't tell anybody was
Special Forces even even prior service
guys and the guy would vanish for months
at a time
and then he come back yeah and he didn't
live on military base he lived in a
civilian house so you know go figure
they don't live on oh yeah because we
went there yeah he was yeah and he had
full auto weapons and [ __ ] like that
[ __ ] that he owned because he could
pretty amazing you saw it yeah yeah I
picked him suppressed mac-10 I reached
down picked it up he was using it in a
photo shoot it was a it was on it was
empty I did a functions check real quick
and it was it was it was full auto
it was firing from an open bolt and it
all that [ __ ] registered real
suppressors everything it's exotic
French [ __ ]
exotic French Bullpups it was the real
thing you know I mean and then I said
dude what do you do or this [ __ ] I got a
license for all that and then later was
walking around his house and saw his
graduation photo and I said dude you're
a snafu yeah young guy you know and you
know later on once you know once he kind
of confessed
I'm telling Special Forces stories he
tells me worry you know what he's doing
now if I ask you know no but you know he
does stuff in other countries and he
comes back and he'll tell me some things
about it but nothing yeah yeah I know
the continent but yeah so all of that to
say like if you were really about us you
wouldn't have to go around telling they
don't tell anybody they don't tell
anybody about it that's how that works
so before we get further into talking
about BTK let's just do a couple of
really quick shout outs faceless villain
Volume one that the audiobook the audio
has been upgraded and replaced so if you
go purchase a copy of it now that's the
improved audio that I recorded with our
new Yeti microphone um so you know if
you were waiting for some reason and you
like you were waiting for me to finish
it it's up there now I'm also redoing
the unseen hand it's all recorded I'm
just editing it so that'll probably be a
couple more weeks before that turns up
but that'll be improved also and then
like I said I'm gonna eventually get
around to doing my fiction and some
other and you know the other shorter
paranormal books and stuff too that'll
probably be later on this year because I
really want to get started on faceless
villain three so I can get it out before
the end of this year just like I
promised I would because I said 2019
that shit's gonna be out I wanted one
out every year so I'm gonna start
working on that like I said I got the
outline and everything I just haven't
like started cracking down on it
so that's that and then also if you
didn't see our last movie review it was
silent scream from 1979 and again thank
you rob for sending us that movie I
hadn't seen it in many years and it was
kind of cool to revisit it also go check
out our zazzle store I added three new
shirts which I mentioned on the last
show I did a bulletproof wolf one but
skinwalker ranch I did a wandering womb
one and I did the infamous shirt that
we've all been waiting for
the Kukulcan yeah I don't have one yet
so if you guys have one you beat me to
it I'm gonna get one yeah we're
eventually gonna yeah that's good I like
that it's it I I think it came out
pretty nice they say so much so it took
me long enough to do it cuz I wanted it
to be really cool you know what I mean
cuz it's it's such an iconic part of the
show like thank you yeah alright so I
think that's all so let's start talking
about Dennis Rader better known as the
BTK killer like I said this [ __ ] is
still alive yeah he's in prison serving
like [ __ ] 750 years or some thing they
they actually Kansas does have the death
penalty now it was reinstated in 1994
but because all his crimes happened
before 1994 like he wasn't eligible so
they had to give him like back-to-back
life sentences and they wanted to make
sure that he would never get out so but
he is he's still alive as of this
recording right so now as far as I know
like he was born in a place called
Pittsburg Kansas but you know when he
was younger his family moved to Wichita
you know kind of a big city um you know
his parents he have like three brothers
and I think his dad was in the in the
Navy I want to say yeah they're Marines
or something like that now they don't
really know a hell of a lot about
Dennis's childhood what they do know is
stuff that he generally told them and
that can't always be trusted because
like I said he had kind of that thing
where he wanted to be famous like a
serial killers so he would you know
write letters to the cops like taunting
them he would write one letter that he
wrote it was like he had like um like
mock titles for chapters of like a
biography of him like if somebody wanted
to write that he's like here I hopefully
wrote some chapter titles for you
like that kind of [ __ ] and you know so
when he got arrested much later on you
know he was talking about his childhood
and stuff now he says that his
propensity toward bondage and torture
happened pretty young he said you know
as soon as he could read as soon as you
know as soon as he was like six seven
years old he knew that he had a thing
for people being tied up and getting off
on that he's probably those crime
detective magazines when I wonder like
the one thing he did say was that he
used to watch the Mouseketeer Club
yeah and that he was he would fantasize
about Annette Funicello like being tied
up and like him torturing her yeah like
when he was a little kid he also said
that he tortured cats and dogs although
like I said none of his other family
members said anything about that none of
his friends or anything like that so I
don't know if that's just something I
mean it's probable that he did that and
maybe he just kept it a secret because
that's something that a lot of serial
killers do when they're kids but I you
know I don't know that's just what he
said um so really he he kind of kept to
himself he had friends and [ __ ] like
that one thing that a lot of people said
about him was that he was like
unremarkable
he was just like kind of a studious guy
one friend said that he had zero sense
of humor um you know what I mean he was
just very very serious and like he
wouldn't like goof around or anything
like that
um which you know that kind of checks
out um you know and he wasn't like into
like joining clubs he wasn't into like
you know the music that was around at
the time or anything like that so he was
just but he didn't stand out really he
was just kind of like I was watching a
documentary about him and they called
him like the Invisible Man he was just
kind of this
this nobody he was just like this
milquetoast kind of someone that you
wouldn't remark upon right you know what
I mean he didn't stand out in any way so
he graduates in 1963 and then he goes to
he starts going to college in 1965 and I
think at this stage he got like an
associate's degree in electronics oh is
that looks like two years um when he was
21 he joined the Air Force and he was in
there for his you know four-year thing
mostly stationed at bases in San Antonio
and stuff like that although he did
spend a great deal of time at some bases
in Japan also he was in Okinawa and on
mainland Japan he and he kind of
traveled around a lot he said he spent
some time in Greece and stuff like that
as well so he uh like I said he you know
he wasn't like a combat he was an
infantry or anything like that he was
like a technical guy he would like work
on equipment he would work on electric
equipment antennas and stuff like that
and he got it to the rank of sergeant he
was he got a bunch of medals too I think
he got like a marksmanship medal and
Good Conduct Medal and yeah and [ __ ]
like that
yeah so you know again his time in the
surface unremarkable you know he had
friends there and they said he was just
one of the guys totally normal they
didn't notice anything weird about him
or anything like that so after he gets
out of the service he comes back to
Wichita and in 1971 he marries Paula
Dietz now these two were married for
like 30 years and that kills me that he
just had this whole family life and he
had two kids with her as well and he
just had this totally normal family life
while he was out yeah [ __ ] murder this
always bothers me man that this dude in
dudes like this will have families and
normal family lives they have a right to
these families but then they deny this
right to other people they go and kill
their family and I'm sure they don't see
it that way but that's exactly what
they're doing I hate that more than just
some insel run around doing it yeah I
mean yeah that's worse and you know what
shitty two is that and I
we watched because um his daughter
Carrie is that she's row now obviously
and she just wrote a book about her
experiences like growing up with him
because she didn't know that he was BT
cancelling until he got caught like in
the 2001 thing that she said that really
made me very very sad was that you know
most people that write to her like it's
now that the book has come out or very
supportive and stuff like that but you
get those percentage of people there how
could you have not known you have killer
DNA and like I was and like like
[ __ ] on her right it's like she was
a little kid yeah how the [ __ ] like
here's the thing if my dad had been a
serial killer I there's no way I
wouldn't have known you probably know
how would you know even if he's got a
job where he's away a lot
that's what I mean and I feel like you
know even the wife because people like
oh how could she be married to somebody
for 30 years and not now I'm like that
doesn't seem all that crazy to me
especially if I mean because his wife
she also worked and you know he worked
and he added he mostly had jobs where he
was away all day so you know who the
[ __ ] knows what he's out there no net
perverted British couple that had those
kids that were murdering those girls
yeah
that was the name what was their names
wait Brady and Hindley yeah her kids I
knew about all the sexual abuse they
were appointed friend rosemary West yeah
they were getting abused themselves but
they didn't know anything about the
murders yeah I think until later I think
they they realized that they did I think
they found out that the dad had killed
that one daughter yeah yeah they weren't
sure if he really had her if he was just
a joke oh [ __ ] yeah Arivu was like just
threatening them Luka oh I'm gonna put
you under the patio so you know they
were living there in the month in the
midst of it mid several those kids leave
two three of them and they didn't know
that's what I mean it's totally possible
and in the case of Dennis Rader I mean
one his murders were pretty far apart um
you know they he do one and then like
three or four months later do another
one then it'd be like three years before
he did another one and he would do them
like usually during the work day like he
would kind of set it all up during the
work day um you know on his lunch hour
and stuff like that so you know and then
he would just come home and act like
nothing happened so how the [ __ ] would
you I mean you would never suspect why
would you suspect
that I wouldn't have you know that's
what I mean my dad always works my mom
always worked if if my dad had been out
like murdering people there is no
[ __ ] way I would have known that I
don't think my mom would have known
either so it's like so it makes me angry
that like that people [ __ ] on the
families like oh well you must have
known like they were responsible for a
lot of them don't know yeah I don't
think and in this case I'm from Gary
ridgway's wife yeah Mitch was going out
there having sex with rotten corpses and
then going back to his wife
and having a safe with her evidently and
how she felt it's like you know it's bad
enough like that you know these serial
killers leave these people that they
murdered in their wake but I think
people forget to it's like their
families are also kind of victims
because they can't have a normal life
now yeah everyone's gonna blame you or
you're always gonna be associated with
this Gary Ridgway - yeah we will we're
gonna get like I said we're trying to do
like all the bigger ticket yeah we got
5,000 subscribers now so we got to do
the big and I've gotten like so many
like requests and suggestions and stuff
like that and I and I really do try to
get around to the mall it's just I have
such a huge list and you know Mulligan
will get around then writing books -
yeah you know what all right so so he
marries uh you know Paula now Paula's 23
at the time dennis is 26 and at this
point dennis was actually working at a
grocery store he like worked in the meat
department like I don't know if he was
just the butcher I don't know what the
hell he was doing in there but he was
working in the meat department and Paula
also had a job she was a bookkeeper I
think at a VA hospital um so then about
a year later Dennis goes to work at the
Coleman company you know the one that
makes like the camping lanterns in tents
and [ __ ] like that um as it turned out
two of his future murder victims were
also employees of Coleman although they
didn't work in the same facility as him
now I don't know if I don't think he
ever mentioned that he saw them at work
or he like you know because he would
stalk people for a long time before he
called them his projects which isn't
that [ __ ] up and he would so he would
stalk them from a long time like find
out were their names and where they
lived and like what their schedule was
and stuff so I don't know if
like found them through work or if it
just happened because Coleman was like a
really big employer in Wichita at the
time so maybe it was just like a
coincidence that two of the victims
weren't there I'm not really sure but he
didn't he didn't work there for very
long he only worked there for like maybe
a little over a year and then I don't
know if he got fired or he quit he said
like because some places he worked at a
long time but I don't know he kept kind
of getting fired from places too so I'm
sure he wasn't like the super because
some people said he was really like a
jerk you know what I mean especially
later on like when he got into more
positions of power and [ __ ] like that so
then okay so he gets his Electronics
degree in 1973 and then he starts going
to Wichita State University and he
starts going to night school now he
wants to get a degree in what he what
did they call it the cop thing justice
justice administration administration of
justice he wants a degree in that so he
learns all about serial killers he
learns all about crime and stuff like
that
even though by all accounts he was a
terrible terrible student because like I
said I kind of feel like from looking at
his writing that he probably had a
learning disability when he talks he
sounds pretty normal although every now
and then he pronounces something wrong
like he was I was watching his
confession and he he wanted to use the
word ruse yeah I remember that
and he said ruff ruff first but then he
corrected himself and then he said it
right like the rest of the time so I so
like I said I don't think he was one of
those ones like Ted Bundy that wasn't
the smart as he thought he was but like
you know I think he was trying to like
he was trying to imitate a educated
sophisticated person yeah I thought that
definitely does go outside his
vocabulary yeah yeah and he didn't
really know how to yeah I think he'd
read that word but had never used that
he never used it in everything and then
when he said it he's like yeah okay so
like I said it took him about six years
but he eventually did get his criminal
justice or justice administration or
whatever degree although like I said he
was like a CD student
you know because of his purported
learning disability yeah he also worked
for Cessna for a short time but was
fired now at the point that he got fired
from that job which was sometime in late
1973 early 1974
so he's unemployed and he starts getting
bored and he starts thinking about all
these fantasies that he is supposedly
had since he was a kid about tying
someone up and killing them and getting
his rocks off on it now unlike Ted Bundy
Dennis Rader actually never raped anyone
what his thing was was he would tie them
he got off on on having power over them
and strangling them like tying them up
binding them and stuff like that then
strangling them and then he would jerk
off over the bodies yeah
so he never actually did any penetrative
rape or anything like not that that
makes it any better I'm just saying that
that's like I did so that was like his
specific fetish was more of the killing
if you ask me and the raping that's a
that's a sign of sexual inadequacy if he
asked me I think you worry about it it
might be he's worried about not being
able to perform and then it would mess
up his the picture of it that he had
yeah it could also be that he made when
did this start 74 he didn't care about
DNA no so that's not was afraid he
wouldn't perform or that he wouldn't be
impressive yeah so you know I mean he
but he might have not been a very
well-built guy yeah
which may have added to this whole
sexual inadequacy thing I've seen the
photographs that he's taken of himself
you know what I mean dressed up as a
doll and we taking pictures of himself
down in a grave this is oh this is
gender-bending pictures of himself never
really explained well he liked to one he
liked to bind himself also not just
other people like he liked to do self
bondage and he also liked to wear the
clothing of his victims yeah and he
would do like stuff too like he would
put plastic bags over his head
put tape over his own mouth you know
[ __ ] like like hang himself from pole
like it and then he would like take
Polaroid he had like a yeah Polaroid
camera that had like a little clicker
thing on a wire yeah me thinking that he
has sexual inadequacy issues if he has I
think that's worth like maybe he might
be he might be kind of like a
self-loathing bisexual something like
that I wonder I mean it seemed like or a
self-loathing transvestite he's
definitely dressing in women's clothing
yeah I wonder I mean it did seem like
his target his target victims were women
and girls um he did kill men too but
only if they happen to where they were
just like an obstacle here's the thing
he's killing these women and girls but
then he's fantasizing himself being a
killed woman or girl yeah being in there
being in their position so it's almost
kind of like he's fulfilling a fantasy
that he has of him being a woman victim
maybe it's like sadomasochism basically
the thing about him is that he doesn't I
mean like I said if you see his
confessions and stuff he's very dry and
like matter-of-fact
about it but he doesn't seem
particularly insightful about why no he
has that well I'll tell you one thing
you look at the guy there's absolutely
nothing feminine about him no nothing
and he was actually you know and like I
said I hate this whole thing of like Oh
Ted Bundy's the hot serial killer and
some like that but I will say that
Dennis Rader when he was younger like
when he was in the Air Force and stuff
like that was not a bad-looking dude he
was just like a normal okay looking guy
you know what I mean like you wouldn't
have thought he was ugly or anything
makes you wonder baby if he had issues
with him becoming in touch with his
feminine side yeah I'm talking about it
could be maybe he thought that made him
gay or something so he was doing weird
[ __ ] there was yeah it's a sexual
dysmorphia of some have some sort
because it does I mean according to him
at least it does seem to have manifested
itself very young because he said that
he did start having these fantasies and
feelings when he was very young yes so
and like I said it I don't know like
they don't know a lot about his
childhood so I don't know like if his
upbringing was messed up or anything
like that it seemed fairly normal no one
ever said anything otherwise
yeah it seemed like people are too
interested in his sexuality sure I mean
they're not writing about it yeah I
haven't heard of any psychoanalysis of
it of the cross-dressing and there may
be some out there although I didn't come
across it like I said most of most of
the stuff that that amazes people about
him or shocks people about him it's just
this double life type of thing that he's
just like led this to a normal life and
no one suspected a thing and that he was
really good at like compartmentalizing
and he even called it that good guys he
could be kind of like a twisted Ed Wood
type guy where he puts on women's
clothing it makes him feel better yeah
you know man but then he has fantasies
of him being victimized and killed yeah
in those clothes it's some weird get
some kinky [ __ ] yeah get some kinky [ __ ]
looks like and there's nothing wrong
with that it's just that he's killing
other people the others I'm wrong with
these kill no I mean there's nothing
wrong with having that fetish that's a
pretty common fetish
it's just that why did it become warped
to such a fashion that it's like you
feel like you have to kill people
because it was very serious and esri and
it was also his reaction to that fetish
that's what I'm saying is like it's a
reaction of having that involves killing
people yeah so it's not right yeah
obviously see there's a lot of [ __ ] you
know people go on and on about gender
and sexual orientation in a weird way a
serial killer is a sexual orientation
but it's a bunch of stuff happening at
once
and it commands up being that's their
sexual orientation death is a part of
their sexuality
murder is yeah and like I said and I've
said this before I think I said that
somehow um you know that I think that
people that ultimately become serial
killers I do think that they are born
with that propensity I don't think that
it will necessarily turn into that
unless they have a particular upbringing
in very rare cases I think they'll they
would just be a serial killer no matter
what just because they're so messed up I
think it's a developed but most of the
time I think that there has to be both
of those factors I think there has to be
nature and nurture factors in most cases
yeah I got a feeling that's a
developmental problem yeah that that
what's happening is very primitive it's
very infantile yeah mixture of advanced
and primitive all happening in the same
person yeah and a bunch of conflicts
yeah that definitely seems to be the
case here like I said and he seemed very
matter-of-fact about having these
fantasies but he didn't really have any
insight unresolved some kind of
unresolved early childhood fixation yeah
I guess really one of the key things you
have to have it must have been yeah
although like I said they don't know a
lot of us because they stay they start
exhibiting weird behavior before puberty
yeah you know or around you know they
start killing animals around 12 13 you
know that's during puberty times a lot
of times it's something developmental an
unresolved childhood issues yeah so
Freud it'd go off on it somehow never
discussed it I don't think he knew about
the phenomenon and yeah 40 in psychology
is very outdated but he would come up
with an explanation for it someone
probably but yes so 1974 Dennis is
unemployed like I said um and he started
getting into the habit of like like I
said his wife Paula she worked at a VA
hospital and that where she worked kind
of far away and in the winter time she
didn't like driving back and forth like
in the ice or whatever so he would drive
her to and from work now when he after
he dropped her off at work and then he
was driving back home he started driving
around on what he called trolling so
what he would do and this was kind of
like his standard MO he would spend and
like I said every time he was gonna kill
somebody he called it a project that's
what he called it so or PJ yeah so he
would start stalking people generally it
was he would have more than one going at
once in case you know he decided to go
with this one or this one
messed up or whatever reason he would
generally like target just people that
he saw like if he just be driving around
and he would see a woman walking down
the street go oh that could be a victim
right there and then he would start kind
of like going driving past there like
seeing when she was home when she was
out of someone else lived there where
she worked like he would go in when she
was at home he would go in her mailbox
and see like what her name was
you know that kind of [ __ ] and like I
said he said that he always had a bunch
going at once so then he could decide
like on the day like which one he was
gonna go after you know what I mean so
so he's been doing this trolling thing
and his first set of victims there's a
family called the Otero family and they
had moved into this house and Dennis had
seen the mom and the daughter now the
mom was named Julie and she was 34 the
daughter Josephine was 11 now they were
a Hispanic family and Dennis apparently
had some kind of thing for Hispanic
women like he liked their hair color and
like he thought we would they were
exotic or some [ __ ] I don't know so so
he was like entranced with these two so
he starts like stalking
now he gets together his little kit
which he called his hit kit and that was
like all his [ __ ] in there his guns he
had a couple of them you know knives
tape all the normal [ __ ] that you would
expect if you're going to serial killer
somebody and so then he starts watching
the house now he knows that the Otero's
you know he knows it's a couple he knows
that they have a bunch of kids but he
thinks when he goes to the house to
actually do the killing he thinks that
only the mom and the daughter and maybe
one of the sons is gonna be home however
when he decides to break in one day this
is January 15th so he he drops his wife
off at work he goes back to the Attero
house he cut the phone line which is
something that he always did he cut the
phone line and then he breaks into the
house and then like usually he hides
in a closet or something like that but
this was his first one so he just busted
in now the husband Joe was there now he
was not expecting Joe to be there so he
was already kind of like off his game
cuz this is his first time it's like
it's already not going the way he
expected also home was their
nine-year-old son Joey
they had three other kids but the three
other kids had already gone off to
school they also had a dog like a really
mean dog and that was also in the house
so immediately like he busts in the
house and he's like you know fearing
that he's lost control already but so he
is armed he comes in he says look I'm a
you know I'm a fugitive from the law I
need food and you know a car blah blah
blah that's what he told them so he
tells the kid Joey he says go put the
dog you know in the backyard and then he
says you know uh all I needs money and
I'll just take in then I'll be out of
your hair now the funny thing will it's
not funny but like the the husband at
first thought it was a joke like he did
he's yeah he's like did somebody like
yeah that's what I mean it does not
immediately what you think cuz it sounds
far-fetched yeah that come on so yeah so
he just thought it was a joke but he was
just like what man are you serious but
no he's it so he's got a gun on him he
tells me old lay down in the living room
then he says no never mind go in the
bedroom instead so he puts he ties them
all up he puts a plastic bag over Joe's
head this is a 38 year old guy Joe
starts fighting obviously as a normal
man would he tears the bag open and
electro anything through it and [ __ ]
like that but then you know Dennis had
to like find some other cord and
something like that and then like start
put a little pull it around his neck and
he actually strangled him and thought he
was dead then he tries to strangle the
wife Julie with his bare hands but he
had never done it before
and I guess he had just like seen in the
movies like it's super easy to strangle
somebody it's really not easy so long
time to strangle somebody so he thought
that she was dead and then he took his
hands away but she was just passed out
so she woke back up and then he had to
go back over there and he either
strangle her with his hands or with a
rope the second time then he takes the
nine-year-old kid Joey takes him into
his bedroom does the whole strangulation
suffocation thing now he said later in
his confession and this is [ __ ]
horrible he said while the kid was dying
he like dragged a chair in from the
kitchen so he could like watch it yeah
[ __ ] up you know yeah so then
Josephine this little 11 year old girl
he tried to strangle her as well but
again now where was she
he was tied up no yeah everybody was
just kind of like I know what happened
everybody else I don't know I know
that's like it the most horrible like if
you're the last one and you have to like
I can't imagine what yeah so Josephine
he tries to strangle her again it didn't
work she passed out she just woke back
up so he actually took the gun forced
her to walk down to the basement he
takes a rope ties it in a noose and puts
it around her neck and puts the noose
over like a big pipe that was in the
basement and like if you stairs a
documentary like because the house is
still there evidently or it wasn't in
this documentary of a shot and the cop
that was the first on the scene he went
down there in the basement and it looks
exactly the same so he showed like the
he's like yeah this is where it was and
then he's kind of strong Ryan yeah watch
it yeah any any sense to the little girl
he says you're gonna be in heaven with
all the rest of them in a minute yeah
like he said some [ __ ] like that yeah
then II asked her if they have a camera
and she's like now we don't have one so
he like half undressed her and then just
like left her hanging on this [ __ ]
pipe and then jerked off on her legs
and then kind of went and he cleaned up
the place
then he took some [ __ ] from the house
like he took like a radio he took like
the dad's watch just like [ __ ] it wasn't
valuable stuff it's just like he liked
having souvenirs I guess so he could
like think about it later
so he takes he gets in their car and
backs out the [ __ ] driveway almost
hits another car but doesn't then he
drives to a grocery store like near
there which is called Dylan's he takes
the car keys and throws him up on the
roof of the grocery store and then he
walks to his own car and then and then
he realizes that he's forgotten one of
his knives at the crime scene so so he
gets in his car he goes all the way back
to the Attero house parks his car in
their garage they're all [ __ ] dead
inside the house goes back in there well
actually I think the knife was outside
like it was in the yard so he gets the
knife from the yard and then leaves
again right holy [ __ ] so like I said now
the Otero's actually had three other
children throw the keys on the roof I
don't know he did that more than once I
think yeah I thought that was weird too
why did you care detail why did he care
if the keys were in it but he just like
yeah he just like parked the car I don't
maybe fingerprints I don't know but he
was wearing gloves though I think he's
tripping yeah I don't know it's just I
know that struck me as a very strange
detail yeah you don't have to do that
that he had like throwing the keys
that's deadly yourself a more danger
calling it calling attention to yourself
yeah don't keys up there anyway what are
you doing man yeah oh I'm just throwing
keys under the roof like marty is trying
to be smarter than he is that's what I
mean it's like what the [ __ ] and like
you said that would if somebody saw you
doing that they'd be like okay that's
super weird I'm called John be smarter
than he is yeah you don't never get
these keys would you do that like it
kind of like if you don't think about it
you're like oh yeah that sounds like oh
wait a second it makes more sense just
leave the keys in the ignition
yeah yeah because so you might steal the
car and then they take the car to
another [ __ ] location they get busted
with the stolen car and then there's
murder [ __ ] thinking dentists stupid
[ __ ] yes yeah yeah so and there's a
shitty thing too is that the Otero's had
three more kids and when they came home
from school they found all the
oh cool teenage kids 15 14 and 13
national yeah great found the daughter
hanging [ __ ] mm-hmm yeah I know a sucker
yeah
so this was in as I said January of 1974
now his next project as he termed it
that just like serial killers piss me
off a lot on Midsummer's not he just
pisses me off
it was just a project every time I see
him I just want to punch him write his
stupid mission number two God [ __ ] out
of here yeah so yeah his second project
was Catherine bright she was 21 years
old now this actually was only a few
months later this happened in April of
1974
now again she was just somebody that
he'd been driving around trolling as he
termed it and he just saw her going into
her house and was like oh she looks like
someone I could kill the body I'm gonna
kill that
yeah I suppose so April 4th he waits
until she's gone he breaks into her
house through the back door and then he
hides in her bedroom now two o'clock in
the afternoon Catherine comes home now
she lived alone he knew that however on
this particular day she was with her
brother Kevin her younger brother I
think he was 19 so they had been out
doing something that like running
errands that day so he came back to the
house - so again Dennis is like [ __ ]
now here's another dude in the house
that he wasn't expecting to be there so
he comes out of the bedroom and he's
pointing a gun at them he tells him the
same thing that he told the Oh Tara
family look I'm a wanted fugitive you
know I just need money in a car blah
blah blah so I'm just gonna tie you up
and take your [ __ ] or whatever he didn't
wear a mask or any kind of decided
disguise I don't know okay because
that's weird because he killed later on
like he killed like a neighbor of his
yeah
like who knew who he was vaguely so I
don't know I thought I I'm kind of
feeling like he did it I don't think he
wore a mask it wasn't like a golden
snake
type situation where he just had like a
ski mask on I think he was just hey
here's my face right like I don't know
he was confident that he was gonna kill
you anyway so it didn't matter that's
yeah that's what I'm thinking he just
thought no one's gonna escape however in
this situation things went awry for him
so what he did was he tells Kevin and
Katherine to go into the bedroom and
then forces Kevin to tie up his sister
and then he tried that he takes kevin to
another room and tries to tie him up but
he hadn't brought his best hit kit that
day I guess and he even said that like
in his confession things like oh I
didn't bring my stuff my good stuff so I
had to like use some [ __ ] that they had
around the house so it didn't work out
as good yeah you know what I mean and
I'm like okay whatever
so he's so here to like improvise he
says so baby coos turn the camera oh no
she said she like puts her mouth on the
little handle thing yeah you're so weird
okay so so so he since he doesn't have
the good [ __ ] and he had to improvise or
he's sometimes Kevin up stop it no stop
it kidding he ties Kevin up but he
doesn't do that good a job so Kevin
escapes um so then he starts fighting
with Dennis and almost got the gun away
from him so knock it off kitty kitty
translate yeah come on Pookie alright so
they get in a fight Kevin almost gets
the gun but then Rader gets it back and
shoots Kevin in the face Kevin is shot
in the face and yet he is still fighting
with this mother father yeah fighting
with this [ __ ] yeah and tries to
like overpower him again yeah a lot of
people think that if you a lot of people
when they shoot somebody in the head
they shoot towards the eyes okay cuz
that's what they're looking at but the
thing is is that the brain is above the
eyes yeah now times the [ __ ] round
goes in the face region and believe it
or not face is not a vital area
yeah go right out underneath the
braincase come out the back sometimes if
it doesn't it this yeah I've heard of a
lot of people get it okay see your face
off and you just be without a face but a
fully intact brain yeah I mean it's not
fun cuz you look at your face is not a
really a vital organ if you want to call
it an organ yeah yeah so so Kevin's
fighting with Dennis he's already been
shot in the face once and then Dennis
shoots him in the head now at this stage
Kevin falls down and he's bleeding from
the head wound obviously so Dennis
thinks he's dead so he just goes back
and starts to try to strangle Katharine
now Kathryn also fought the [ __ ] who's
like fighting him like really really
really hard and he was like couldn't do
like he couldn't strangle her and so he
eventually ended up just stabbing her
because he couldn't get strength cuz she
was just fighting him so hard yeah so he
stabbed her that's a lesson to you girls
you can't fight it's better to fight
well she did die never let anybody take
you anywhere never let anybody tie you
up ever that's what I am I would just
better to fight to the death because I
figure they're gonna kill me anyway
they take you somewhere they're gonna
kill you if you're tight tying you up
they're gonna kill you alright probably
slowly it's better to go down fight and
early on I would rather yeah that'd make
them kill you yeah if it comes to that
and maybe you'll [ __ ] hurt them poke
their eyes out right yeah so she fought
the [ __ ] out of but you know he still
ended up he couldn't strangle her but he
ended up by stabbing her like three
times in the abdomen and she actually
ended up dying later because what
happened was he stabbed Kathryn and then
he noticed that Kevin had gotten up and
had run out the house and was screaming
for help
shot in the face shot in the head and
he's running down the street screaming
yeah he wasn't a big dude he was a
skinny guy so I saw interviews yeah
there's an interview with him on some of
the documentaries one of the interviews
I saw said that he was a slight build
back in those days he might be a little
bit bigger but he was you know skinny
kid yeah but yeah so he actually took
and so Dennis was like okay well this is
all gone sideways so
he basically just ran out the house he
kind of cleaned up around the house
really quickly like he he would usually
he had hid clothes that's what he called
them you know he had like an outfit that
he's gonna that he was gonna throw away
later so he didn't like leave clothes
anywhere he's like destroyed that I
heard that some people attacked the
brother how could you leave your sister
in a situation like that he did the
right thing he did yeah get the [ __ ] out
of there I mean then it minimized that
minimize the death toll and try to find
help because he couldn't handle the guy
yeah and the only chance was for him to
go get and she didn't die right away um
they actually the police came you know
they took her to a hospital she got
surgery she got blood transfusion stuff
but unfortunately she died anyway after
a few hours now Kevin survived so the
interesting thing is that when Dennis
started taunting the police with and
keep in mind when I say Dennis they
didn't know it was Dennis Rader until
2004 this is - this is 1974 they didn't
know who this guy was for a really
really long time so he just like sent
these messages to police like in these
weird like circuitous kind of ways and
they had no idea who it was
now the kathryn bright murder he
confessed
you know when he would say how many
murders he had done he usually said like
the names he would say the i'll tear the
Otero's or whatever he never really
confessed that one even though he said
oh I did another one but he wouldn't say
that one and I don't know if it's
because he messed it up or if because he
knew that Kevin could identify him
that's what I was wondering about that's
why I was wondering when you said about
wearing a mask because I'm like if Kevin
lived he saw what that mother [ __ ]
looked like yeah he didn't want his
description out and didn't want so he
never really took credit for that way he
would say like he had too many
fingerprints on it yeah and and like I
said any cousin David had gone to the
witness and said what exactly did he
look like you know what it passed around
this has a serger this is what we think
he looks like yeah because I guess
because it went so drastically out of
his control that he didn't want it maybe
it embarrassed him too and he didn't
really want to say like he he would take
credit for a murderer that at least like
oh I did another one but he wouldn't say
like
what the victim's name was like he did
with the other ones so I just you know I
kind of wondered about that like I said
we know about the masks and everything
all right so we're getting about to the
halfway point so let's take a break
right now and then when we come back we
will talk even more about Dennis Rader
aka the BTK a kill
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why they're it's so
significant because we are willing to
put pen to paper and conclude at the end
of the day that this house is very much
haunted and will continue to be odds of
a long time oh oh well you're right
thank you that's it that's it
oh come on she's like come on I'm gonna
go get Mama's foot then yeah yeah they
didn't know the faceless villian a
collection of the eeriest unsolved
murders of the 20th century vol 2
includes cases spanning the years from
1960 through 1979 featuring such
infamous crimes as the triple homicide
at Lake Bodom
the family massacre known as the good
heart murders the serial killings of the
Zodiac Bible John Jack the stripper and
the freeway phantom the slaughter of
dozens of women and girls along the
highway of tears and the Texas killing
fields and the mysterious death of
suspected spy the is doll woman along
with dozens of other fascinating and
horrifying accounts buy it now from
Amazon in print Kindle or audiobook
format okay we're back talking about BTK
bind torture and kill but yeah so
October 1974 now police had recently
arrested either a guy or a couple of
guys for the Otero murders none of whom
were Dennis Rader now apparently Dennis
Rader was mad that somebody else was
getting credit for [ __ ] that he did
mm-hmm
so what he did was he he wrote a letter
and he hid it in a an engineering book
in the Wichita Public Library then he
calls the editor of the Wichita Eagle
newspaper and tells them where the
letter is the editor calls the cops the
cops go to the library and they find the
letter now
a letter is a very very graphic
depiction of what happened to the Otero
family had details only the killer would
have known so obviously they knew that
this was the actual killer that it said
this he said I did it myself with no
one's help because like I said he was
afraid someone else was getting credit
for the show and he was annoyed about it
now like I said if you read this whole
letter it is horribly horribly written
it is just like it's just the spelling
and the grammar is just atrocious I've
never seen anything like it was it was
it consistent though consistent and like
did he always spoke that where was he
did he dumb his writing down to evade
detection do you know I have heard
people say that that maybe he was trying
to make it seem like that but from
everything else that I've read about him
they're like no he really was that
stupid because some people did like
float that idea that maybe he was just
like oh he's some big super genius and
he was trying to come across as a dummy
but I told him across with somebody else
yeah but see I feel like he was one of
those ones that wanted the fame so if he
was really a super genius he wouldn't
want to make himself look he wouldn't
want to make himself look like a dumbass
so he obviously didn't know any better
like he didn't know how to spell or
anything like that okay so in this
letter he actually comes up with the
name for himself you know code words for
me will be bind them torture them kill
them BTK might have been this letter or
another one where he came up like I said
he came up with some other names for
himself
yeah cheesy [ __ ] names one of them
was like the poetic strangler - man what
the [ __ ] so now it waited killer okay
Lord Byron right yeah that's not it well
and that might have been later because
he did actually like write some poems
obviously they weren't very good poems
about some of the some of the victims
and some of the ones that had gotten
away you know hmm so now even though
he's done he killed a family of four he
killed
one woman and almost killed her brother
so but then there was a gap now in
November of 1974 Denis starts working
for ADT security and he got up to I mean
he worked there for like 14 years
managing company yeah yeah and yeah
they're still around right and so
essentially he was going around he was
an installation supervisor so he could
go around in case joints yeah and he
could case joints like it and advise
people on alarm de and he knew how to
get around alarm systems because he
installed them for a living
yes so there was that whole thing going
on and since he was an installation
supervisor he could go around in the
company van like all day long and say he
was working but he could really be
trolling so you know what I mean so it
was like win-win for him from his point
of view so yeah now in 1975 him and his
wife Paula had a son named Brian so they
think that because he had got another
job because he had a new baby this is
probably why there was this big gap in
the killings they don't think he
committed any crimes between 1974 and
1977 although he did say later on when
he was caught that he was always
trolling like he was always fantasizing
about the next kill and like planning it
and like checking out victims and all
that kind of [ __ ] now there wasn't
another one until March of 1977 so it's
like three years so he's been drunk kind
of driving around this one neighborhood
now he had met this one girl named
Cheryl in a bar and he knew that she
lived with another female roommate
nearby and that they had parties and
stuff like that so he was kind of like
considering that this was gonna be his
next victim either just her or her and
her roommate so he was he had planned
this so when he went to the house on the
day that he was gonna do the killing no
one was home so and they interviewed
this woman on one of the documentaries
because they're like you were had you
been home that day you probably would
have got murdered but luckily she was
not home that day so he's frustrated and
he's all in his words he said he was
keyed up so since his intended target
was not home he was gonna go try and
find another one so he goes and starts
casing this other house in the
neighborhood and looks around but
there's nobody home there either
then he's walking down this street
called hydraulic Street which I thought
was in a really weird name for a street
you know what the hell would you know um
and he sees this little fight some
hydraulic plant there I get yeah yes so
he sees this little five-year-old boy
named Steve Rufford now he says to the
boy that he's a private detective he
takes out a photograph of his own wife
and kid and says do you know who these
people are and the kid was like
obviously it was like now I don't know
who that is so then he watches the kid
to see what house the kid goes into now
in the meantime he goes to like another
house I'm like trolls in there but
there's no one there either so then he
goes back to the house where the kid
went into so he comes to the door says
again that he's a private detective and
then he gets into the house so there's
Steve is in the house he's five there
was another kid in the house a little
boy who was eight and a little girl who
was four Dennis comes in the house he
turns off the TV he closes the blinds
and then he pulls a gun out now the mom
comes out her name was Shirley by Anne
she was 24 she comes out of the bedroom
and is like what the hell is going on
out here
now she had stayed home from work that
day because she was sick she had the flu
so she comes out she has a bathrobe on
he says okay well I have a weird sexual
thing I have to tie you up and rape you
you know he says I have a sexual problem
ursa yeah I remember him telling I have
to tie you up and rape you and then
it'll all be over and it'll be fine hold
on one second one sec what's that I've
seen interviews where Rader is talking
about his sexual problem alright he's
explaining to investigators what I told
her you know and how he says sexual
problem is [ __ ]
and hilarious it is yeah I was just I
told her I had a sexual problem sexual
problem yeah yeah it's just [ __ ] this
[ __ ] was something else man I
have sexual problems yeah I have to tell
you I've been right here
Oh be like that sounds like your problem
or mine it's a sexual problem yeah
that's a [ __ ] problem already so he
says I'm just gonna rape you and then
I'll leave it's a sexual problem and I
mean he had a gun so she was like okay
fine so he's like okay well we're gonna
like barricade the kids in the bathroom
so he puts like blankets and toys and
[ __ ] like that like in the bathroom and
then he locks all the kids up in there
like barricades them in there like with
a piece of furniture showing some [ __ ]
like that
so then he says to Shirley like like I
said she was she had the flu so while he
was talking to her she barked so any she
had to go he let her go get a drink of
water he let her have a smoke cuz she
was like freaking out is this is another
thing like when he was doing the
confession thing he kept saying like
every time like his victims it's like
well at this point she was pretty upset
yeah
you think do you think that she was
probably pretty upset yeah she was
probably pretty [ __ ] upset yeah yeah
Arnie upset well you know of course she
was she was upset she was pretty upset
I'm like oh my god this he just makes me
so so mad I mean they all make me mad
but that just for some reason that just
my shoes I was watching I was I had to
keep turning it off because I'm like I'm
gonna have a rage stroke if I don't
understand it you know I'm trying to
rape and kill a [ __ ] and you know they
get upset they get upset right that's
exactly how it came across that's
exactly I get that tablet is their
problem I don't know why I have no idea
why they'd be getting mad I'm laughing
because I'm [ __ ] pissed at these
dudes so don't make me I'm not allowed
any people dying that's what I mean you
have to laugh and like I said it's just
that just maybe so so angry like when he
said that's me I'd be kicking Rick
Dennis's ass gone you get a little upset
aren't you Dennis yeah
yeah yeah I don't even think it was
[ __ ] work I don't know but yeah I
said my flesh off that man he'd be very
upset yeah yeah let's hope let's make
him very unsent so give me a blowtorch
in about four hours yeah so this poor
girl so he says he's just gonna rape her
but of course that was a lie he tied her
up and then strangled her and she had
told him that her husband was coming
home but in PR he knew that because he
had kind of well actually he didn't know
that because this but she was just
random he was targeting somebody else
and she just happened to be her kid
having to be walking on the street
running an errand he was like I am but I
go to that house farmer right so yeah so
he her husband did actually come home
like later on and he found her the kids
what what ended up happening he
strangled her then he jerked off into
her underwear yeah and then like a man
does right and then the kids he said the
kids kept like banging on the door yes
I'm trying right like they kept banging
to get out and then the phone started
ringing yeah and then he said okay well
I have to get the hell out of here so he
was gonna kill the kids as well right
but since the phone rang and they were
making so much noise he's like and the
windows were open right so he was like
well I thought that I've made so much
noise I can't kill these kids right yeah
that's what I mean is that's what me I'm
so much like everything is like oh my
stop me from doing right like everything
was just like such an inconvenience yeah
it just came across like that phone
ringing I think that's a sexual problem
and I'm like and I have to deal with
that why the [ __ ] are you I don't know
yeah so as I said this was March of 1977
now a few months later December 1977 he
has been stalking this other woman named
Nancy Fox and she's 25 um he's been
trolling and he's been stalking her for
quite a while he found out her name he
found out where she worked like what her
schedule was and everything like that so
December 8th Sheila
duplex and she lived by herself and I
don't think anybody lived in the other
half of the duplex either so she was
kind of in this big house like all by
herself um he cut the phone line and
then broke in um so any hit in her house
now she worked at a jewelry store at
night I think she had a couple of jobs
so she comes home um and she's in the
kitchen he pops out with the gun and he
tells her the same thing it's like I
have a sexual problem got a psycho
problem um I need to you know rape you
so that's how that's 1977 there's a [ __ ]
ton of serial killers running around
this time yeah I mean you even got you
got buddy running around in 77 don't you
yeah we've talked about that before I
don't know what the [ __ ] I think it was
I think it was a combination of led boil
and leaded gasoline know their mothers
right didn't have access to abortion I
think yeah so you had a lot of like I
said I've heard that said because these
[ __ ] should have been aboard crime
rate dropped like like 18 to 20 years
after Roe vs. Wade right so getting all
those [ __ ] oh yeah yeah now if you
don't want to sound inhumane the getting
rid of the excess unwanted population
has certain benefits well it's just that
if if a woman is poor and she knows like
look I'm a drug addict or I'm poor I
can't afford this I don't uh I'm not
ready it's better for her not to happen
it's just like you know what I mean
because if you do and she can't provide
for it or you know what if she's
addicted to drugs what if she's in an
abusive relationship what if you know
what I mean there's all these things and
it's like you bring a kid into it and
that kid's gonna be messed up yeah it's
like it's not the kids fault and but and
these serial killers tend to come from
basically working-class or low-income
white families yeah yeah so like I said
I do think that was the kind that would
be aborting children nowadays yeah I do
think that's definitely a factor like I
said I think the lead thing might be a
factor too I've only seen that mentioned
like one other place well hey man
they'll talk about ancient Rome having
all kinds of problems or drinking water
that came out of
red pipes and eatin awful LED plates
yeah all right but they don't want to
mention that leaded gasoline yeah those
cars back in the a I was there during
that time that was putting some [ __ ]
particles by unleaded leaded gasoline
yeah that was blown particles out the
back of the exhaust pipes and that [ __ ]
wouldn't go anywhere just come blow
around inside cities yeah well where's
all this happening in cities a lot of it
yeah you know suburban areas because
there was a high population density you
don't really hear about it happening too
much out in the country I bet you that
lead was a factor there's little LED
particles ever oh yeah like I said I'm
sure it's not the only one I'm sure it
was like it but confluence of factors
but I think that was probably one lad it
led evidently Connell lowers inhibitions
yeah and look you had all of the weird
sexual [ __ ] that was going on with
sexual revolutions and weird
there was weird [ __ ] going on back then
too you know and it was violent yeah
there's a violent time when it really
really I don't think it should have been
a violent time I bet you was that led
I'm just saying people so pretty much
this thing with the Nancy Fox went
almost the same way as the surely Vian
thing now he did um he tied her to the
bed you know and undressed her and
undressed himself and he straight-up
told her I'm the person that killed the
Otero's like after she stitch after she
was tied up it was so so at this point
even though he said poor she was in her
that you know I'm she was upset yeah and
I think he said that - like what they he
just kept saying that like every time he
was just like yeah they were pretty
upset correct oh my god but yeah so so
now that she's tied up even though he
said before oh I'm just gonna rape you
and it'll be and then I'll leave yeah
but now that he said oh I killed the
whole [ __ ] family and putting little
kids it's like he's probably like well
[ __ ] Wow for some reason she was a
little bit upset about that yeah so same
kind of thing he strangles her to death
and then jerks off into her nightgown
now the next morning he goes to work and
then he goes out in his little company
car or van or whatever he stops at a
phone booth
and then he calls the police yeah it
says you'll find a homicide he said how
much Nancy Fox yeah and then he told
them the address and then he leaves the
the phone receiver like hanging from the
phone booth
so the cops go there and stuff like that
now they the interesting thing is they
play the tape obviously as they would
they played the tape on the news and
everything like that and nobody
recognized his voice
nobody Nancy Fox yeah a homicide yeah
homicide that's what he said look I said
what the [ __ ] doesn't matter with him I
don't know but um yeah so then he starts
his little you know quasi zodiac [ __ ]
again he sends a postcard to the Wichita
Eagle newspaper in the cup first couple
months of 1978 and he had written a poem
on it called Shirley locks like Shirley
Vian was one of his victims but the
problem is it got sent to the mail room
and I guess nobody knew that it was from
him or nobody knew what it had what it
was pertaining to so it just kind of got
left on a desk somewhere um so I don't
think they'd even found it until later
on
um and then a couple days after that
they got another letter that they knew
was from the killer and in that one he
said you know I killed do terra's I
killed Shirley Vian I killed Nancy Fox
and I also killed an unnamed seventh
victim who was obviously Katherine
bright and like I said he never directly
took credit for that one either because
the brother lived or because he was
embarrassed yeah he also was trying to
justify what it was that was making him
kill people he oh my goodness whoa
that's Beijing it's Beijing she had that
Beijing out yeah she came in here
yelling she's very demanding are can't
speak we know exactly what they're
talking about they're not communicating
okay you go inside to play all right
back right back to 70k yeah and his
sexual problems yeah problems I want
sexual problems oh yeah like I said I
got very upset
understatement of the century course you
know that kids upside yeah that's
exactly in a way it was like humble
bragging he was trying to say they're
terrified of me yeah I see through that
[ __ ] yeah Dennis I would [ __ ] you up man
[ __ ] you up you're lucky you're behind
bars
yeah good [ __ ] you up dude yeah I think
I wouldn't even need any of my guns I
wouldn't even need a knife just hands
I'd [ __ ] you up this what she did to
those families you're behind bars for
your own protection
yeah consider it a blessing okay it's
not just me other dudes would [ __ ] you
up too that's what I mean I'm sure yeah
I feel like we made the people would
[ __ ] you up all right you're behind bars
for your own protection dicks so is so
in this latest letter that he sent to
Wichita Eagle he was trying to explain
what it was that made him want to kill
people he's called it various times he
called it factor X yeah well I'm very
special you know yeah all right you know
sometimes he called it something like a
demon he even like kind of drew a
picture of it and it was like really
weird because it was just like this
little it almost looked like a cute
cartoon bug okay yeah that's how he saw
it the whole thing you know maybe never
what was Mickey can tell me well and I'm
just like maybe want to rape a [ __ ] and
jerk off into her panties Joe yeah it
was real honorable you know and had a
higher purpose like you know wait like
I'm just glad that it's weird to me
because I'd be worried if that [ __ ] made
sense yeah that's not good now also in
this letter and again this is another
one of the poems quit moping around
you're like making this [ __ ] off focus
I'm running a cool calm pretty hard
that's my man he's a time he keeps like
swaying around it like it keeps on about
make a general chicken I got general
chicken and then back in there that I'm
gonna cook up Oh deep-fry that [ __ ] up
and yeah yes it's Friday night one
that's right now it's all good and also
he included a poem that was called Oh
death to Nancy that was based on it was
based on like a banshee Fox a folk song
called
Oh death which was actually they they
speculate that he might have learned it
in one of his classes because they did
teach it and like one of the literature
classes like it wichita the university
he was going to so they think he might
have got it from there but he life
changed it so it was specific to that
[ __ ] victim now when they got this
letter the police were torn because
they're kind of like okay well clearly
this guy is a psycho and a serial killer
but just as clearly he wants attention
and fame do we want to give him that
but he's like then on the other hand you
know the public has a right to know that
there's a serial killer running around
and they need to take some steps to like
perp to protect themselves you know to
the extent that that's possible yeah so
they didn't really know what you do
they're like we don't really want to
like get this guy what he wants but you
know on the other hand we want to
protect the public - so um you know in
the end they decided to go ahead okay
we're just gonna have to go ahead and
like publish this douches raving which I
agree with that
you'd have to because if somebody got
killed because you didn't pay enough
attention then that would be on you
nobody wants that I believe that that
was a better call to go ahead and sit
and [ __ ] satisfy an attention-seeking
[ __ ] [ __ ] like this [ __ ] right here
yeah because that could have saved maybe
one or two people yeah it was worth that
he wasn't gonna stop yeah but that might
slow it down yeah and give them more
time yeah it's like it's the right call
like I said it's like I'm I'm not really
look in general I'm not a big advocate
of like giving attention to [ __ ] like
this that want it but I'm something with
the situation this situation I think
they did the right thing because he
seemed to be the type of dude that if he
didn't get attention like because I
think the second letter he was like hey
what the [ __ ] like I sent that
postcard before and like nobody said
anything about it so he was getting
angry so that might have made him lash
out I would think that in an offender
like this giving him some attention
would slow down his cravings yeah so he
would have killed less people that year
yeah it might have been so yeah like I
said it's a hard call to make but I
think they did make the right call in
this situation of just like giving him
the attack yeah kid wanted you're right
but um the the [ __ ] up thing is that
during this whole time that he was
stalking Nancy Fox and like murdering
her and stuff like that his wife Paula
was pregnant with their second child
well you know you know I had these
sexual problems yeah and my wife you
know I mean it wasn't working out so I
had to go outside the marriage
unfortunately yeah now they were upset
you know rationalization they were a
little upset but it all worked out yeah
you know I'm answering for it now yeah
which that'll make it all better
that's it yeah yeah that's like he
didn't say that but that sounds it's
exactly what I weigh that's what he's
talking about like something he would
say that's the thinking so so this kid
was Kara I can't bring him back yeah but
I can answer for it and that's even
better than bringing him back they're
not thinking of others they were
thinking of themselves you know what I
mean they're grand izing themselves you
know hey taking responsibility for my
crimes that's better than having those
[ __ ] back yeah it's almost kind of
like they do really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and
they say they're sorry and then
everyone's just supposed to be like
pretend like nothing happened yeah yeah
I said I was sorry what else I can do
yeah I don't understand that at all I'm
like yeah but the [ __ ] way that you
did is still UN you know I I said you
win that's so happy yeah it's like you
can't fix it just by saying the magic
word yeah so like I said so this kid was
Kerry like I said she's the one she's
grown now and she she recently like put
out a book
what it was like like growing up for
them because the creepy thing and I
watched like a really long interview
with her um in this poor this poor woman
she is like um she had no idea she's
like he was just totally normal
took them to Disneyland took him camping
she's like I loved my dad you know yes
like hung out with my dad it's like I
never you never like would have imagined
that now when she found out um she she
wrote him letters I think she wrote in
one letter and she's basically like you
know I still love you but I don't
understand this and but she has never
been to visit him and I don't blame her
yeah
so it's just it was just a really [ __ ]
up thing and that is just watching the
interview with her like made me really
sad like I'm sure she doesn't like want
people to be sad about her and stuff
well he gave them a good childhood
because that was a duty and it reflected
on him yeah you know I mean and now but
that's not if you ask me that's not who
those guys are
yeah he put up a good illusion of being
a good father that's not what those
dudes are yeah it's just weird to me how
he could separate it out because I mean
he had a wife he had two kids he had a
normal life he had a normal job and it's
like you know every now and then he
would go off and do his quote unquote
projects and no one suspected anything
but it's like and this I think we talked
about this in one of our other shows too
so I'm like did he actually really love
his wife and kids
or care about them or not is he capable
of it I don't think they're really
capable I don't think they have the
emotional that's what I mean I don't
think they're capable of it maybe they
can find real good I think everything is
a reflection on what they do yeah it's
part of the whole packing right I have a
wife I have a kids and I'm good to them
because that reflects good on me yeah
that's what that's what you do that
that's what you do and it's all just
like an explorer by them it's an
extension of his self-image right I'm a
good father because I'm good yeah like
you I don't you could take those kids
and replace them with anything else and
he'd do the same thing yeah
you know I mean see that's kind of what
I suspect too because I'm like look if
you're just going out killing random
people there aren't I'm supposed to do
you can't care about door - opposed to
this what you're supposed to do this is
what makes you you know makes you good
person now I have sexual problems and I
gotta go I got to get out of a I'm on I
have to strangle a [ __ ] you know no man
turbine torture and kill I might have to
you know put on some women's underwear
and take pictures of myself you know
pretend like I'm one of the victims yeah
like sometimes you have to do this just
ever do it evidently yeah yeah I've
never felt the need to do things but you
know you know whatever its factor X yeah
that's what he that's what he's talking
about
yeah all right it's the whole family man
persona doesn't have anything to do with
the wife and the kids has to do with his
own self image yeah that's how he
fulfills his self-image you know I'm
talking about it's serving him yeah it's
like a possession
it doesn't even do with him it's just
like an outfit right like he's normal
yeah okay makes him feel like he's
high-value and that he's prestigious
yeah that's all it is the reflection I'm
good to my kids and visits it's good for
me yeah basically
everyone will know that I'm a good
father
yeah because that's what you're supposed
to be because that's it everything about
it holds society together and you have
to have a society for me to deal with my
sexual problems that's trigger [ __ ] if
we're not ratio and you say yeah yeah
yeah well if you don't have a society
you can't break into people's houses and
rape a [ __ ] yeah you know I mean
strangle them and bind up and torture
and kill them you can't do that without
a society you know that's you have to
look at it from that point of view
what wouldn't be subversive what be like
I said I'm not sure he's like smarter
insightful enough know to actually like
consciously not a comparison no but I
think it was it was emotional and an
extinction in instinctual for that to do
it that way so all right so April 1979
um
Dennis has had another project it's this
woman named Anna Williams now she's 63
years old she's a widow her husband has
just died I think watch your column
Coover well what he said later on was
that he was tired of he's like look I I
knew that I was that you know when he
whenever he had gone after younger women
they generally fought him a lot of times
there were men there that would also
fight him okay so it seemed like he's
like well I'm gonna start going after
older woman cuz they're more vulnerable
yeah so yes so that's kind of what his
thinking was on that and he did actually
admit that so this was a six a might not
get ISM sir so he breaks into her house
like like I said he's been trolling and
watching her and stuff so he knows what
her schedule is he likes in her house
and waits in there yeah but she didn't
she doesn't come home that night or she
came home like much later than she
normally would he got bored and left
like he took some [ __ ] from her house
right and then he was like pissed off
anyway he was upset and he left how dare
you not be here yeah so broke a date
with me right I think that's how he
thought of it because a couple months
later he mailed her a package like to
her house and in the package that was a
poem that was called Oh Anna
why didn't you appear he had drawn like
what he would would had been planning on
doing to her and the [ __ ] that he had
taken out of her house he sent that to
her house and he sent like copies of
that [ __ ] to the ka ke TV station in
Wichita
this woman Anna Williams breached the
[ __ ] out as you would and move to the
[ __ ] out of Wichita I was like yeah no
[ __ ]
so what I now at this stage they don't
think he killed anyone again for several
several years no is he still working for
ADT at this point uh yes I think he
worked there for until 1988 okay I want
to say yeah so during this time when he
wasn't killing anybody he was still
doing the trolling thing he said he'd
never stopped doing that he was always
trolling always looking always
fantasizing about you know his next
thing but he just didn't do one for a
long time now his son Brian at one stage
got old enough to be in the Cub Scouts
Oh Brian joined the Cub Scouts and he
became like a Cub Scout leader and also
got very active in his like I think it's
like a Lutheran so he's like a Lutheran
Church and he eventually got it he was
like president of the Church Council or
some [ __ ] like that so this is you know
from the outside if you didn't know any
better um you know oh he's a Cub Scout
leader he's like the leader of the
church council he's has this job for 14
years
he's a totally respectable individual
who just happens to [ __ ] strangle
people this is all things that serve him
and his self-image yeah that's all it is
yeah that's exactly what it is so he's
an approval seeking [ __ ] yeah
now then comes 1985 now this is April
27th and Dennis is at like a Boy Scout
camp out like outside of the city now he
had been stalking their neighbor marine
hedge she was 53 she was also widowed
now she only lived like right down the
street from them and she knew him like
she knew the family because she's like
the family would walk by the house you
know he said we would walk by their
house sometime and she like worked out
in their garden all the time and so like
they would wave remember her she wasn't
liking ya an older woman yeah so so he
so he knew her
I guess he decided wish to me that seems
like a stupid move but you know so he
decides that she's gonna be his next
quote unquote project my guess he
figured well they'll never suspect in
this area I killed so many people in
other areas now however they would
suspect that I have anything that's what
he's saying yeah he didn't really go far
afield I mean I think everyone he killed
was in in Wichita Wichita yeah he he
wasn't like Ted Bundy where he just like
would go to one state but she wasn't the
first victim it's more likely that a guy
first victim is somebody who lives near
him yeah
yeah I mean so it gently wasn't the
first one so he knows well this is gonna
be concerned a BTK killing and she
wasn't the first one so they wouldn't
and like I said he had a degree in
administration of justice he he knew
knew all about serial killers and he
knew he knew about law enforcement tech
yaks and in the patterns so he knew all
that
so April 27th he's at the Boy Scout camp
out and he says he tells them he's like
oh I have a headache I have to go into
town and get some aspirin or something
like that but really he was gonna go
kill her so he parks his car like by
this bowling alley
he buys a beer and then like he swishes
it around in his mouth and kind of pours
it on himself and then starts acting
like a drunk so he calls a cab and he
tells the driver um
take me to this park that's over here
he's like I gotta walk it off you know I
gotta go home and I'm kind of messed up
so he's like acting all drunk and [ __ ]
so the cab drops him off in this park
which happened to be like right behind
marine hedges property was like right
behind her backyard so he gets out the
cab and he sees that Marines car is in
the garage or in the ER in the driveway
rather so he's like well [ __ ] she's home
cuz he thought she wasn't gonna be home
and he was gonna break in the house and
wait for her like he usually did um so
but he's like okay well maybe she's not
so he cuts the phone line he sneaks in
the door like he pried the door open
with a screwdriver and um actually no
one was there so she was out with
someone else but you know in their car
so he hides in the closet like in her
bedroom
so marine comes home and she has like a
man with her named Gerald Porter so they
had been out in his car so they come
there like they hang out and talk until
like 1:00 in the morning
Gerald leaves and that DISA and Denis is
in the closet like this whole [ __ ]
time so he waits until oh man waiting
that Klaus yeah and then so he waits
until marine like goes to bed and goes
to sleep he comes out of the closet
turns on the bathroom light and then
jumps on her and then he actually
strangled her with his bare hands
she was you know she was a little woman
she was only like a hundred pounds or
something like that now this is a new
wrinkle that he's added because it's
been a few years since his last one this
last one was 1977 this is 1985 so he
strangles her to death he drags her out
the house puts her in the trunk of his
car he goes to the church that he's the
council that you know leader at yeah
yeah and he like takes her out in the
woods behind that he had keys to the
church and soon he could get in and [ __ ]
so he takes her out of the basement he
puts like tape and [ __ ] like over the
basement he takes her down in the
basement he like ties her up in various
positions and like takes pictures of her
and then he takes her out and then like
dumps her like on a dirt road or
something like that wait he takes a
bunch of pictures of her they all laid
out
yeah even dressed her up
he may have dressed her up there's a
long time ago she researched it recently
but I remember it from back in the day
that basically what he was doing is he
was kind of trying to make like a layout
before portfolios this one it's kind of
like porn he's making his own form yeah
that's exactly what he was doing all
right and in a way it might make sense
from his point of view because it's more
efficient he could enjoy that for a
longer cuz he could of course he's gonna
beat off to that [ __ ] mm-hmm which has
been a long time since he's killed
someone he's probably thinking well I'll
kill this one and I won't do it for a
long time so I have to
[ __ ] you know make this one last yeah
so the whole photo photographing of the
body and all these kind of like
seductive POTUS Azure he thinks they're
dissing
I'd never saw the photos you know no I
don't think they're I don't think
they're available to the public
I've seen the ones of him that he took
them himself but I mean I'm sure the
ones that the victims are probably a
rock somewhere but I don't want to see
that it you know it was a shame you know
she she's a woman under in her 50s and
she was a good-looking woman in her 50s
you know um
and he just ii killed her you know for -
yeah he so he dumps her body like puts
him like [ __ ] branches over something
like that takes her carpark see wipes
all the fingerprints off or whatever and
then he goes back to the Boy Scout camp
where he where he had been and so he
just kept those photos like they still
he still had them like when they
arrested him many years later so his
next victim was vicki wegerle she was 28
years old she lived with her husband and
two children um and he had been Dennis
had been stalking her for quite a while
he should walk back and forth by her
house and he would hear like playing the
piano in her house he shows up on
September 16th and he's in like a
telephone repairman outfit like with a
hard hat and all that kind of [ __ ] and
he says I have to come in and like check
your phone lines and everything like
that so he comes inside the house she
was there and I don't know if the two
kids were there or not but the husband
wasn't there so he comes in he had like
a little gadget that looked like a phone
testing thing so he's over there like
[ __ ] with the phone like look I'm
doing some official [ __ ] over here then
he pulls a gun out forces her into the
bedroom he tries to tie her up but again
she fought him and this is why later on
he started going after older women
because he you know he was going after
the younger ones but they kept fighting
him you know what I mean and he wanted
somebody that wasn't unless the woman's
a strong lesson to you women out there
fight don't go along with fighting yeah
well make them kill you if you have to
Yeah right so he actually ended up
getting the better of her then he
strangled her using pantyhose took a
bunch of pictures of her um she again
had also said that her husband bill will
be home soon
he Dennis actually stole her car or sold
the wegerle car and was like leaving and
Bill wegerle was coming home and saw
Vicki's car like passing him and was
like who the [ __ ] is driving that you
know I mean so it's like freaked out so
he was the one that found her and now
the fucked-up thing their two-year-old
son Brandon was still in the house he
was just like in the living room crying
or whatever so I don't know if Denison's
the emerita just left him there probably
doing that so
BTK he's drunk they they found Vicki she
was still alive but they took her to the
hospital and she died later on
BTK is driving around getting rid of the
evidence and you know getting rid of the
car and blah blah the shitty thing about
this one is that so there's seven in
1986 for a very long time because they
didn't know this was a BTK killing or
you know they didn't know who BTK was
they thought that the husband had done
it and his life was essentially ruined
by them suspecting him like I don't know
if they ever like arrested him but they
kept like the police kept him on their
radar like you know what I mean there
was like all this [ __ ] in the media
about like he was probably the one yeah
so that so it seemed like the suspicion
that he had done it like hung over him
until they actually like caught BTK okay
so in 1988 Dennis gets fired from ADT
they said it was because he wasn't
getting his work quarter completed he
was [ __ ] raping too many [ __ ]
couldn't get his working work done I
guess that's what it was so yeah so he's
like out of a job at this point he got a
temporary job like working for the
Census Bureau like gonna round out the
census or whatever um so at this stage
and like I said before he's starting to
go after older women because at this
point he's 45 years old and he's like
you know younger women are too much
trouble because they're fighting him and
like you know yeah when the men are
there like he's they're also fighting
back
so he's trying to make his life easier I
guess and like um for women who are less
desirable is less competition isn't it a
fight younger men to get to these young
women I guess so his next court unquote
project was a 62 year old woman named
Dolores Davis now she yes she lived uh
not that far away from him although I
don't think he knew her but he had just
again like with his other victims he had
just happened to see her and say hey
that looks like a victim and then like
started stalking her and following her
around um you know and she also lived
alone which was like a big plus now this
is the same kind of thing he did with
the other [ __ ] where he was gonna be
away for a weekend like at a Boy Scout
camp and he did the same kind of thing
like he he came up with some excuse like
I have to go do whatever and then you
know he instead of doing what he said he
was gonna do he goes and he changes that
of his Scout uniform and he turnt you
know changes into his quote unquote hit
clothes and goes to Dolores his house
now in this case he hangs out outside
it's like freezing cold then he takes a
cement block and like throws it like
busts open like the sliding glass door
now Dolores comes running out of the
[ __ ] [ __ ] because she thought a car
had driven into her house because it was
like really loud and he tells it the
same thing it's like you know I'm a
criminal on the run from the law it's
like any table um so and then that's the
same kind of thing like he strangled her
with a ligature then he he didn't take
pictures of her but he did do a sketch
of her I've seen the sketch it's kind of
[ __ ] up looking so just like he did
with the previous victim he takes the
victim he drags her out of the house
puts her in the trunk of the car and
then you know takes her somewhere and
takes pictures he also did the same
thing he did the thing again where he
took the car and then tossed the keys
onto the roof of her house doesn't make
any sense really weird but then like he
then he like walks back and like
so yeah so he's like taking pictures of
this now in this case I think that he
went back the next night and took
pictures again like with the body where
he had dumped it now this was where the
very famous photo of him in the grave
yeah that was the grave that he had Doug
Fir DeLorean if you guys see this [ __ ]
you need to post a picture of this [ __ ]
I have one yeah okay I can't understand
it this grown man taking a picture
himself he had like a doll mask on he's
wearing [ __ ] full-on a Merry Widow
type outfit from what I remember he's
down in the grave yeah that was a great
that he dug for her and then he gets
down in it like he had the Polaroid in
him like I said he had a like the little
clicker thing like on the wire so he
could take a picture for himself yeah
this is creepy yeah and he took a bunch
of pictures of her as well like her dead
body like all tied up and stuff now at
this point like I said the thing that
everybody says about Dennis Rader's is
like oh the dog catcher or whatever now
at this point this is where he gets that
job like about four months like after he
killed Dolores Davis he gets the job as
a compliance and animal control officer
in Park City so this is basically you
know you're the guy that goes around
making sure everyone is complying with
you stupid little like how long your
grass can be and your dogs not an
elysian and according to pretty much
everyone this guy was like a total petty
tyrant yeah and would you know just he
was just like hassle people for the like
the stupidest like minor [ __ ] like all
the time he took his job seriously they
gave him a job he took that [ __ ] [ __ ]
seriously yeah now there were several
complaints against him and honestly I
think like a couple people even sued him
yeah but the problem was oh and also he
was sexually harassing a woman that
worked in the same office as him but the
fucked-up thing was that he was her
superior so every complaint that she
made would just go back to him so he was
just kind of like nope
you would just like throw it out I'm
like why that be who that was that to
happen what he was doing he was going
out of us going out on the road and if
he found cute women and where they lived
he'd go over their knee measure their
grass hey [ __ ] with him about [ __ ] like
that you [ __ ] a woman woman about her
dog and nearly drove her [ __ ] crazy
yeah okay okay he had her dog put to
sleep
yeah Jasmine was the dog's name yeah and
it's because she was a good-looking
woman and she was a good-looking woman
he didn't like it that she had had her
boyfriend yeah yeah and he even said I
mean she was on a couple documentaries
to where she even said that he would
just like harass her all the time he
would look in her windows and he would
like say oh will you just need to get
rid of that dot that guy and all of this
will stop she would go in there and kill
her though he said that [ __ ] yeah and he
had her dog put to sleep too I don't
understand that [ __ ] and I would have
gone to the feds or something with that
there I mean you know it sucks because
it's like it seems like there's not a
lot you can do in that situation like it
was people you could report it to but
it's like would they do anything
nowadays you just get a lawyer okay
LuAnn [ __ ] yeah that's just that's
[ __ ] up you would have vanished
instantly yeah just that people weren't
really this is pre-internet era yeah
people didn't really know how to deal
with problems with the state that well
yeah you know somebody from that from
the state comes and [ __ ] with you you
can just go in there and google it how
do I do with this [ __ ] yeah and [ __ ]
you'll get an answer get you a lawyer go
to this law firm right here yeah they
can't do that people can't harass you
for that kind of stuff
although honestly like and everyone has
a camera now everyone has a cellphone so
she could have easily in that way I
think a lot better now because I mean
even if no one does anything about it
it's like at least you can document what
two people are [ __ ] doing all the
time because apparently that's what this
dude did if he if he liked you or
thought of you is like a project a
potential project or a victim like he
would [ __ ] with you like you know your
grass oh your hose is the wrong color
you know oh your dog is not on a leash
he would do [ __ ] like that like I said
penny
oh [ __ ] that was back in the day when
dudes thought they could do this because
she was a woman by herself yeah if there
was a man around there he the whip that
dudes ass yeah that's what would happen
yeah yeah right so now like I said he
hasn't killed anybody for a while
you knows cuz many years went by now
what brought him back out of the
woodwork again was this guy named Robert
Beatty he was a lawyer in Wichita and he
was concerned that people had started to
forget about the BTK killer because
they'd been such a long time since he
had killed anybody so he's like well I'm
gonna write a book about this you know
just to keep his name in the news now
apparently Dennis Rader got mad that
someone else was going to be taking the
glory and like taking the glory wafer
because nobody knew it was him at this
point
so he's like this other guy is writing a
book about me I want to tell my story so
they think that's kind of what brought
him back out into you know the light
again and got him to communicate again
so that you know at this stage January
2004 it was the 30th anniversary of the
Otero murders so the Wichita Eagle the
newspaper ran like a big series like
about the killings and like reminding
people about it about the upcoming book
and everything like that so Dennis is
like okay well I need to do something to
kind of bring attention back on myself
so March 17th he mails a letter to the
Wichita Eagle now the what do you call
it the the address line like on the
envelope he called himself Bill Thomas
Killman Beatty yes yeah and in this
envelope
he had photocopied photographs that he
had taken of vicki wegerle
at the murder scene and he also had
photocopied her driver's license so he
put that in there so they knew that it
was actually the killer he signed it
with his little BTK symbol that he made
up because like I said he's trying to do
some zodiac
he's trying to brand himself so after
this letter which got forwarded to the
f.b.i he sends a second letter this was
in May of 2004 he sends this to ka ke TB
of the ABC affiliate in Wichita and this
like a he's trying to be the zodiac for
real he sends like a word puzzle kind of
thing with his little signature on it
nobody has ever been able to figure out
what the word puzzle is I don't know
yeah so they couldn't figure that out
but they did confirm that it was from
him um about a month later they found a
package that was taped to a stop sign in
the middle of Wichita and inside this
package there was a letter talking about
the Otero murders and like he had drawn
like a sketch of Josephine Otero the
little girl that he had left hanging by
in the basement so he had left a drawing
of that in there also you know there was
some they he called it the sexual thrill
is my bill that's what he called it and
this was warehouse Angie yeah quite a
ninja Laura T that's what I mean all of
these serial killers like edge and I
[ __ ] hate it or just like knock it
out yeah so this is this is the letter
also where he sent like the thing with
the chapter titles like for biography
about him I guess because like I said he
was really mad that like somebody else
was writing a book about him and he
wasn't gonna because that he hadn't
killed anybody for a long time at this
but this is 2004 you know he hadn't
killed anybody that they know of since
you know eighty six eighty so it's like
yeah so there was that whole thing so
then about another month month and a
half later there's another package and
this was found in the book return of the
Wichita Public Library now this had a
letter in it that said I have spotted a
female that I think lives alone and or
is a spotted latchkey kid I don't know
what does that mean
yeah latchkey kid that's usually looking
little kids yeah after school what a
spotted mean yeah well I spotted like a
leper
spotted like you spotted her I don't
know like I said the dude can't write
yes
[ __ ] he says I just got to work out
the details I'm much older not feeble I
have to have to condition and have two
conditions myself carefully also my
thinking process is not as sharp as it
uses to be uses uses to be I think fall
or winter would be just about right for
the hit got to do it this year or next
time is running out for me now
in this letter he also claimed that he
had killed this 19 year old guy named
Jake Allen now when they looked into
this Jake Allen had actually killed
himself by laying on train tracks why
you would want to kill yourself like
that I don't know but yeah they
determined that that was a suicide and
this was like a fake thing but he was
like taking credit for that now well I
got a question was that he says that his
thinking isn't as clear as it used to be
when he was young that what he said yeah
or his condition what is he talking
maybe he's talking to his physical
condition
cuz I'm I'm nearly 50 and I think I I
think a lot more clearly than I did as a
teenager I mean come on I think it was
sorry about it I think he was talking
about his physical condition like I said
that's when he started going after older
women like in the later years because he
was afraid that he wouldn't be able to
fight it was not a 70 year old man yeah
he's only 40 he's like younger than me
and yeah what's he talking about no
maybe he's 50 now I think he was older
than that actually because he was 45 in
the 80s like the ladies like when he did
that one murder so but this point this
is 2004 so he's considerably let me tell
you young lipid whippersnappers
something I'm coming up on 50 and
actually my thinking is more clear and
and more accurate than it was when I was
in my twenties it was easy to fool me in
my well because a lot of the [ __ ]
falls away a lot of the [ __ ] Falls
when you get older you realize with
you've been lied to about well and you
can focus better
I feel like right I don't think I was
talk I don't think I really started to
focus all that well until I was in my
late 30s yeah I don't know what this
[ __ ] talking about I mean yeah old
people sometimes are not mentally sharp
but there's a lot of other factors that
cause them not to be mentally sharp
illness is one of them they're in bad
physical shape they're not thinking
about anything outside their own
illnesses and their own [ __ ] plummet
towards the grave if you got bad health
bad [ __ ] heart problems or bad
diabetes at 70 you know like my dad yeah
you get kind of like mentally you know
they're not thinking about the same
things we are so what the [ __ ] is this
guy talking about like talking out his
ass I think when he says condition I
think he means physical condition okay
because like I said that's why he was
going after all okay because he couldn't
I I think he was worried that he
wouldn't be able to restrain younger
women anymore cuz they would fight well
he was in bad physical condition he
didn't work out he wasn't a fiscal guy
yeah yeah but yeah so alright yeah you
know look at look at guys like [ __ ]
Sylvester Stallone he's there's 70
something years old that [ __ ] ripped
he's [ __ ] huge yeah it's just because
you know Dennis you're weak man that's
all so in October of 2004 there was
another BTK drop this was a manila
envelope that was left in a UPS box it
was found by a UPS worker this had like
a bunch of cards in it that had like it
had like pictures of kids and women and
he had like kind of pasted them together
so it looked like they were bound up and
they had like [ __ ] ligatures on them
and [ __ ] like that um also he had
written a poem threatening one of the
main investigators on the BTK case also
he had written like an autobiography but
all of this [ __ ] in there was untrue
right so he was like trying to like he
was he lied about his birth year he lied
about who his father was he lied about
where he lives all this other kind of
[ __ ]
now the cops weren't really sure if it
was factual or not but they said well
here's what we're gonna do the FBI
advised them they said just play along
and keep him communicating because
eventually he will make a mistake he did
yeah and he did so that's so the FBI
were actually really smart in that they
said don't don't offend him just keep
communicating keep like playing into his
narrative and eventually he will [ __ ] up
and we will catch him so yes so there
was another drop in December of 2004
there was actually it was a package and
it was like leaning against a tree in a
Murdoch Park and he opened it and there
was like a doll in there that had like a
little plastic bag over his head and
[ __ ] like that he was really into like
putting little packages with dolls and
like leaving them with like its little
hands of feet tied together and on the
feet he had tied the driver's licence
like Nancy Fox's driver's license to the
feet of this doll that had this [ __ ] on
it yeah so the guy that found the
package you know contacted the police
and contacted the TVs and everything
like that now at this stage dennis has
become president of the Church Council
again no one suspects a thing yeah just
think he's a normal dude um so 2005 like
early 2005 he leaves another package he
puts it inside a special case cereal box
because I think he thought that was
funny like serial killer serial you know
because he always left stuff and like a
couple times he left seven like cereal
boxes like one time it was a post
toasties box and this time it was a
Special K box maybe you didn't know that
there was a different spelling that's
well yeah I'm not this maybe he thought
that was the same thing he's like oh
serial killers killer I'm the Captain
Crunch
but you know like I said so he takes
that he makes the package he writes BTK
on the Special K box with all the stuff
in it and then he wrote bomb on it as
well and then he
throws it into the bed of a pickup truck
in a Home Depot parking lot that
belonged to one of the employees of the
Home Depot now the employee just saw
this [ __ ] in his truck and like threw it
out yes well it's like garbage he didn't
like look at it's like a [ __ ] empty
he thought it was empty cereal box so he
threw it away now a couple days later
you know they realized that he had left
this thing there and like you know they
were able to dig it out of the trash and
like that was in it now they actually
looked at the surveillance tape from
because I don't think even though Dennis
had worked for ADT for many years I
don't think he realized that there's
[ __ ] security cameras everywhere
these days
so they actually saw him putting it in
there but he was like too far away they
couldn't tell who he was but by
measuring the you know the the distance
between the wheels like of the car that
they thought he had been driving they
thought it was probably a Jeep Cherokee
which it was so yeah nowadays they'll
get your ass from [ __ ] gate
recognition you heard of that yeah your
walk can give you well yeah because
everyone has a distinctive one all right
but like I said at this stage like I
said it's mm it's early 2005 like they
saw him on the tape like putting the box
into the thing but he was too far away
to like identify so you know so at this
stage he says this box the Special K box
had a bunch of [ __ ] about it about who
his intended victims were like oh I
picked out this person that person he
also said I live in a three-story house
it's rigged with bombs to explode if
anybody comes in there and everyone's
like yeah now this was the point in the
Special K box I love this he asked the
detectives working on the case this is
hilarious to me if I send you something
on a floppy disk yeah will you be able
to tell where it came from or will you
be able to identify no no and they said
no answer me like in a in a classified
ad like in the Wichita Eagle like given
by Maya you know with my name is Rex or
whatever like you know by an ad in there
and tell me if it's okay we'd never know
who you were right and that's
the funny thing is that he was such a
cop groupie that he thought the cops
would be like nice to him he thought I
would tell him the truth he thought cops
couldn't lie he was like no tell me tell
the truth you know yeah he's like joke
out there like yeah yeah scouts honor
right yeah you can't track me - oh never
track you [ __ ] that mother they're
gonna use metadata metadata of course
[ __ ] her he was [ __ ] stupid I know
that well like I said he was getting up
there in age it's like [ __ ] booze
yeah so he's like yeah running out and
tell me if it'll be alright cuz I'm
gonna send you some [ __ ] like on a
floppy disk now there was another drop
in a cereal box this was found on
January 25th 2005 and this was somebody
he had sent a postcard to the TV station
saying hey there's worthless boxes
because nobody had found it and it was
again it was another cereal boxes post
toasties and it was like that he had fed
he had like left it on this sign I've
seen pictures of it like he left it it
had been there for awhile so I guess he
had to like send a postcard to tell him
to go find it cuz nobody had found it
and it had the same kind of thing and
had the doll in it that had the just
like the little girl that got hung then
there was another postcard came on
February 3rd that was to the TV station
and the return address was from Hat cake
man who I guess was like won some
character that that TV station and used
to used back in the old days and he said
something about you know sorry about
your little newscasters oh they've had
colds or something like that and he's
like sorry about your colds and then he
said something about I'm waiting for the
newspaper like to tell me if it's a go
like I'm running a test you know with
the disc and all this other kind of [ __ ]
like his he thought he was [ __ ]
important and [ __ ] so then there was
another drop on February 16th this had a
letter and a piece of jewelry presumably
belonging to one of the victims and the
infamous floppy disc it was a little
purple disc and it was it
titled test floppy for WPD review
Wichita Police Department so even though
they had run an ad in the paper that
said Rex it will be okay
that's what it was supposed to say like
if he if he couldn't be tracked so they
ran the ad that said that and then as
soon as they got the district yes and
then they found in there they looked at
the metadata and in one of the it was
like a word document or something like
that that had been deleted the metadata
led them right back to the Christ
Lutheran Church and they user named
Dennis Dennis
so all they did was Google Dennis Christ
Lutheran Church he was the head of the
Church Council so they put his stupid
ass under surveillance all you have to
do is just [ __ ] go to the [ __ ]
Church and then as soon as they do name
Dennis oh yeah yeah oh there you go and
then they drove past his house and saw
that he had a Jeep Cherokee and Harold
yeah and then so they like I said they
put him under surveillance cuz that's
not that's circumstantial that's not
quite enough they can't get a conviction
arrest him right now interesting now
here's something that is a little bit
controversial
now some sources at the time said that
his daughter turned him in that is not
the case what ended up happening very
much like in the Golden State killer
case was that the cops subpoenaed her
pap smear fraud when she was in college
yeah and took DNA from that yeah and
then matched it to DNA from him and so
they knew that's who it was
that's how they did it cuz because she
was on there saying that's kind of
[ __ ] up it's like you know that was
she's like now everybody knows about my
[ __ ] pap smear Thanks
you know cuz they didn't ask her she
didn't know so she didn't turn him in
they they just used her DNA like without
her knowledge they subpoenaed one of her
medical records from the college so they
so they knew it was him so they had the
arrest warrant so he's coming home
February 25th 2005 he's coming back to
his home like on his lunch break lunch
break or whatever and they'd all swarm
on him and arrest him now as soon as
they put him in the car he didn't put up
a fight anything he seemed to know that
he was busted so as soon as he gets in
the car
he says you know hello mister land where
who was the name of the guy that was
stalking him and he says hello mr. Rader
yeah and of course he's gonna [ __ ]
start thinking oh the adventure begins
now I finally get my recognition yeah
now when they first like put him in the
room like he played dumb like he said he
did I don't know what you're talking
about I'm an upstanding citizen bla bla
bla but once they told him about the
disk in the DNA then then they couldn't
shut him up right I still have the
sexual problem yeah then they can show
he talked for hours and hours there was
like 30 hours or something like that
yeah he was getting all chummy with the
cops
he was young to be a cop he thought that
he and the cops are on the same team
yeah and that they worked together he
astonished that they had lied to him
about the floppy disk to me that's an a
realization of AA we were trying to
catch you yes stupid [ __ ]
what do you think this is that's
dishonest like we were like cool with
you going around strangling people it's
our job to put you in jail
yep understand something that's
dishonest oh man it has to be a man of
honor you know I asked him yes where
pinkie swear you can't track me through
this can you lie to me yeah he was very
he was very upset yeah that their user
if that they had lied to the police
should never be liars
of course that of course that that
that's what that just shows how stupid
this [ __ ] was that he's actually
not the cops to be like yeah send us a
floppy dude we totally can't trace we
can't trace you that yeah is he really
that dumb oh he is yeah yeah nice so
yeah so after that they got him he
started confessing to everything they
went and searched his house they found
photos that he had taken to the victims
they found [ __ ] that was taken from the
people's houses so obviously they knew
who the [ __ ] this was like I said that
the horrifying thing was that his family
were completely blindsided by the
they had no [ __ ] idea that this dude
was BTK they had been living with him
all this time and they had no idea his
wife actually filed for emergency
divorce because apparently that's a
thing and they granted it immediately
she was just like what the [ __ ] just I
can't and so they just and she just like
disappeared and I don't [ __ ] blame
her no um like I said I've seen Carrie
has been in the media talking but the
her mom has not been and like I said I
don't blame her because I would not want
any part of that [ __ ] no way um so
so that whole thing happens now she
ended up interestingly the the house
where they lived there was some kind of
there was out like all these kind of
legal battles about it because they were
gonna put it up for sale for some like
it wasn't that much it was like fifty
seven thousand or something like it
wasn't a big house it wasn't a like it
wasn't a shack or anything like that but
it was just like a little modest house
and somebody actually they put it up for
auction and somebody actually offered
$90,000 like just to be a good Samaritan
because they thought that it would go to
the wife right but then there was like
all this contention about well we don't
think she should we think the victim
should get it because the victims had
sued they they knew they weren't gonna
get any monetary you know reward because
he is indigent at this point but they
wanted to ensure that he wasn't going to
make any money off of his story like by
selling it to newspapers or books or
whatever so that that was why they did
that to like forestall that they didn't
really think they were gonna get any
money out of him but so there was this
whole legal thing about the house and
like we don't want the wife to get it we
want the victims to get it bla bla bla
so there was this whole kind of thing
eventually they ended up just [ __ ]
braised in the [ __ ] so it's like it's
not even there they just tore it down
it's just a lot now if you see there's a
documentary with Carrie did the daughter
and she actually goes to the lot like
with the host of the show or whatever
and one of her it's creepy because like
one of her sleds that she haven't she
was kid is still like in the backyard
like she's like oh my god that's
and it was like a shovel back there just
like I think that was my dad's shovel
and it's just like left there and I was
just like I wonder probably somebody's
stolen it at this point on eBay
that's yeah that's what I mean I'm sure
I was I was actually gonna look on ebay
to see I said that's probably on there
now and I said no don't depress me too
much I'm not going to but yes so so like
I said so Dennis Rader he actually was
going to plead not guilty at first but
then his family talked to him and were
like dude just plead guilty it's like
don't put the families through that so
he did actually come out later and plead
guilty at which point that's where the
the very famous you know video of him
it's like this confession man talking
about it that's what that was like that
was the sentence his confessions [ __ ]
like problems and he almost seems like
it's like every day goes he seems like a
non-person
yeah like he seems like a robot in a
skin suit it's a joke he really does
come across like none of you guys out
there [ __ ] serial killers [ __ ]
knock that [ __ ] off and [ __ ] don't
think that [ __ ] people are gonna
understand that [ __ ] they don't [ __ ]
know normal people don't understand that
because we don't think like that I hate
to be the one to like you know newsflash
you're not gonna know you but normal
people don't think that way and they
don't got an why do you think that was
stop what you do it yes so as I said
since all of his crimes had been
committed prior to 1994 when the death
penalty was reinstated in Kansas he was
not eligible for the death penalty even
though the prosecutors did try like hell
to try just like maybe he committed
something after 94 that we can you know
give him a definite death penalty on but
they never could find anything they
don't think that he committed any more
than the ten crimes that he is you know
that he was charged with and that he was
convicted of because they didn't find
any other stuff in his house right that
you know that suggested that he had
killed anyone else they found stuff from
those victims
because he took souvenirs but they
didn't find stuff from any other victims
and there were like no other unsolved
crimes that were the same MO that they
think were him yeah I'm not saying that
he might not have committed but their
pressure they're pretty sure that those
ten are the ones that he committed and
those were the ones he's convicted of so
from what I remember because I looked
into this years ago
I think after his main stream of [ __ ]
homicides he went dormant for a long
time he only did this you know what two
more and he got caught yeah he was
coming out of retirement it seemed like
to me that he wanted to get caught
a lot of the seems like they do right
maybe it just gets old like after a
while because you're always worried
you're gonna get caught I always had
this think of it yeah I had this [ __ ]
theory dad he thought he was gonna get
caught when he didn't he was like wow
you know what I gotta get caught because
I can't take credit for what I've done
yeah I mean like in a weird way it's
like they want to get caught so they can
grandstand and take credit yeah it
seemed like he got bored I think that
was kind of the whole thing about
because it seemed like he didn't kill
people when he had other [ __ ] going on
his life like I have a job I have a new
baby you know when he had [ __ ] going on
he was able to like rush it back into
the background
and not do it it seemed like he got old
and bored he says you know what maybe
I'll resurface and all I'll kill a
couple more yeah cash in on all this
that's what it seemed that's probably
exactly what is thought process was
because it didn't because he got away
with it really long that's the shitty
thing right you got away for a long time
yeah they didn't catch him until like I
said his first car miss 1974 they didn't
catch him till 2005 yeah and I remember
it back in those days where he got
caught and I was just going over this
case I was like this dude active is
acting like he wanted to get caught
yeah at a certain level like I said I
think a lot of them do after you know
especially if they haven't been caught
for a long time
right that's kind of I mean even if
you're a sociopath it has to weigh on
you it has to be stressful being worried
about getting caught all the time I
would think but I don't know they don't
they don't have the same [ __ ] family
was his kids were grown and gone yeah
he's in the wife yeah he's with his wife
maybe the marriage really isn't you know
it's it's not exciting to him anymore
and his job and [ __ ] you know what I
mean it's not really a big deal see he's
like well it's time for me to finally
cash in on all my credits yeah I gotta
[ __ ] take credit for this [ __ ] you
know so the world will know that I was
the BTK yeah cuz he didn't want to sit
around just getting old and [ __ ] the
collection retirement check it seemed
like to me yeah maybe I'm wrong I don't
know but I don't know that sounds that's
just the timing seemed because he seems
very narcissistic right well I want
everybody looking at me I don't want I
want to go out and a [ __ ] boys a
glory yeah it was like that kind of
thing cuz he seems again like one of
those dudes that they're unremarkable
yeah they can't they're not really good
at anything I don't stand out right and
that's the only way they know how
attention to themselves but it seemed
like he's by doing that yeah that's like
the only way they can become famous I
remember I was going down man I was like
do this he definitely wasn't trying to
get away with this
yeah you know I mean he wasn't trying to
get away with it
well like I said he did get away with it
basically he [ __ ] his [ __ ] mouth shut
yeah you know well I mean look at the
[ __ ] zodiac he wrote all kind of
letters and they never caught that
[ __ ] yeah although I'm kind of
hoping they will know that they're doing
they're doing the all the DNA [ __ ] like
they caught the Golden State killer so
kind of good cuz I'm curious to know
yeah he's dead I think he's probably
dead by now although I'm really curious
to find out who the [ __ ] that was he's
dead though yeah a long time ago but
yeah so this [ __ ] did get caught
and he is still alive he got a minimum
of a hundred and seventy five years
they said they wanted to make it so that
he would never be eligible for parole
because of their legal thing so they
they were like he wouldn't be eligible
for parole until 2180
which that'll think that [ __ ] is gonna
leave me like a hundred [ __ ] eighty
years right unless he like something
like that which I don't think anyone's
gonna give him that but yeah so still
alive but hopefully not for that much
longer and that will do it for our
discussion of the BTK killer Dennis
Rader hope you enjoyed it if that's the
right word to use remember if you like
the show to like share subscribe on all
your social media if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page there's
patreon.com/scishow
every now and then we put up like little
extra videos and [ __ ] like that so go
check it out if you don't like patreon
but you'd still like to financially
support the show anyway you can go to
our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
done WordPress comm and there's a link
in the sidebar it's a little button and
you can go to our PayPal account and
give us like a one-time donation
remember to check out our last movie
retrospective which was silent scream
also check out our Zazzle page
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock we've got
some new shirt designs on there that you
might want to check out Rama kook on I'm
running with cool con right now check
that [ __ ] out also check out my geology
store on the game crafter dot yeah it's
a good game I have a bunch of games on
there that you can check out and buy if
you would like to and that will do it
for episode 134 we will see you next
time bye
you